china's president xi jinping has struck
a defiant tone at celebrations marking
the 100th anniversary of the country's
communist party
at a major event in tiananmen square she
called for the country's reunification
with self-rule taiwan he also
warned that anyone attempting to bully
china would quote
get their heads bashed observers see the
comments as veiled threats to western
countries that have criticized
china for its human rights abuses and
crackdown in hong kong
she's hour-long speech followed a
military flyover
cannon salutes and patriotic songs in
honor of the ruling communist party
now it has been a turbulent century for
china under the party
the party started with a secret meeting
of 53 people
in shanghai in a house in 1921.
it has since been transformed into a
colossal instrument of political control
with some
92 million members across the country
after decades during which the people's
republic of china was
essentially closed to the rest of the
world under founding leader mao zedong
the once impoverished nation has been
transformed
into the world's second biggest economy
the party and its current leader
xi jinping appear to be riding high
from opening the world's second largest
hydropower plant
to launching the highest luxury hotel on
earth
to celebrating its triumphs in space
the chinese communist party is turning
100 and it's marking its birthday with a
propaganda blitz
to highlight its stability and strength
and justify its increasingly tight grip
on daily life in china
this week's celebrations will highlight
china's rise in recent decades
and glorify early days of struggle under
founding father mao zedong
the communist party has ruled china for
72 years of its hundred year history
no other dictatorship has been as
successful at expanding international
influence
adding military muscle and overseeing
economic growth
the party will gloss over policies like
the great leap forward
in which millions starved and the
cultural revolution of half a century
ago
and there'd be no mention of the bloody
crackdown on pro-democracy protesters
at tiananmen square in beijing in 1989
this week the party will be all about
promoting the success of its marxist
leninist political system
and of boosting supreme leader xi
jinping who enjoys more power than any
leader since mao
china's brand of state capitalism
weathered the global financial crisis
while many richer nations floundered
and despite initially mishandling the
coronavirus outbreak which started in
wuhan
china's economy is back on course while
most other countries are still barely
coming out of lockdown
but while china celebrates there's
growing international unhappiness about
china's more aggressive approach
on the world stage about the oppression
of uyghur muslims in xinjiang
and about the dismantling of freedom in
hong kong
and let's cross over now to
correspondent matthias bollinger who
is following the celebrations in beijing
matias
i'd just like to begin by asking you we
heard during the ceremonies that
president xi jinping
said china would no longer be bullied
what message is he trying to send the
world
well the message is first and foremost a
message to the chinese people the
communist party uh uh defines its its
legacy its legitimacy
by uh what they call having liberated
china from foreign powers from colonial
powers
um that was of course uh a long time ago
72 years ago
when martin founded the people's
republic but with communism
uh and and and marxism being
less and less uh visible and important
in china
this nationalist message is the most
important that the communist party has
then this never be bullied again is
something xi jinping has been
repeating that is how he sees his role
he has finally established the strength
of china
after the liberation china become
wealthy under them shopping and now
xi jinping sees himself and
paints himself as the man who has made
china strong again a strong military
that defends its interests its perceived
interests all over the world and
of course what he means is uh
refers to all kinds of disputes that
china south china sea
taiwan and it also refers to criticism
from abroad
the communist party is less and less
tolerant for those
who do not share its worldview given uh
that criticism matthias what can the
world expect from the chinese communist
party in the years ahead
well that's always hard to say xi
jinping has made it clear that
he wants to unite as he called it taiwan
with the mainland china
he wants to most likely conquer taiwan
because there are no
whatsoever hints that the taiwanese
people might voluntarily join
this people's republic whether this will
happen or not will depend on a lot of
things but
the threat has been more and voiced more
and more often
in the past few years mathias how are
people
um you know in hong kong in in taiwan
for example
likely to view this day or or we also
have to say you know chinese who have
fled abroad
well um in hong kong this day is also a
special day
it marks the 24th anniversary since the
handover from
britain to china that was usually the
occasion where the hong kong people
would march
for their liberties for the uh protest
against the grip of the communist party
now in this past year
the communist party has tightened this
grip with a new national security law
that has been that has come into effect
one year
ago exactly so for the people of hong
kong
of course the moot is very different
than from those who attended the
ceremony in beijing at the tiananmen
square
matias bolinger in beijing thank you
[Applause]
and for more let's bring in richard
mcgregor senior fellow
at the australian think tank the loewy
institute and
he's written extensively about china's
communist party
uh how has the party changed the country
over the past 100 years
well you know the party wasn't in power
until 1949 and from 1949 until about
1978
you know the party changed the country a
great deal but it didn't enrich the
country
china really only took off after mao
died
and since then if you've got 1.4 billion
people in an economy growing almost
every year at about 10 that's not just
going to transform
china that's really going to transform
the world and that's what we're seeing
unfold in front of us right now and and
we're also seeing china of course
asserting itself
more and more on the international stage
against that backdrop that you have just
mentioned xi jinping in fact
warning in his speech that foreign
forces attempting to bully the nation
will quote
get their heads bashed what do you make
of that
tough talk well i guess first of all
this is for
you know a domestic audience for
domestic consumption
um you know all politics is local china
is no different in that respect but
i think you know there's also a message
for foreign countries particularly
western countries particularly the
united states
you know china still thinks and also all
plays up
the the idea that foreigners want to
keep china down
foreigners want to contain china xi
jinping used
the word today enslave china in other
words foreigners want to do to china
what they did during the colonial period
and that is really a highly motivating
line of reasoning for him to use and it
creates a kind of
emotional connection with people in
china who can still get very
angry and emotional about the past
and we know that you know many of these
foreign powers
watchdogs for example they have been
putting the spotlight on human rights
abuses
in china itself for example in xinjiang
also the crackdown on free speech in the
pro-democracy movement in hong kong
all of these have come under intense
criticism
in which direction do you see the party
heading
well very much in its own direction you
know when china was poorer it took no
notice of western criticism of human
rights now that it's richer it's going
to take
even less notice and in fact you know is
all
trying out all manner of ways to fight
back and put its own story which by the
way have been
largely unsuccessful in convincing
public opinion in western countries all
of those different
um issues you mentioned xinjiang hong
kong
you know later on taiwan they all have
their own dynamic
uh but i think um in their own sort of
you know context
but i don't think that china is minded
to change
direction on any of those issues uh in
the short term
i'd like to ask you just briefly before
we go uh you know president xi jinping
is set to be ruler for life if he wants
i'd just like to ask you
how did he pull that off how has he held
on to it and what does it
say about the state of the chinese
communist party and his grip on it right
now
well it's quite remarkable he's really
overturned you know a few decades of you
know incremental institutionalization of
you know
peaceful transfers of power he should
have been stepping down at the end of
next year nobody's expecting him to
so it tells you both number one he's an
extremely powerful leader
number two he's a very worried leader
because he doesn't feel like it's safe
for him to step down
number three uh he wants to he thinks
you know has a sort of messianic sense
of leadership and mission
that only he can carry china to the you
know modern
end point that he set for it
richard mcgregor joining us from the
louis institute
thank you so much for your insight on
this chinese centenary of the communist
party we appreciate it
thank you now back in
1978 china was an impoverished peasant
state
a communist party under deng xiaoping
decided to bring in a rural reform to
increase agricultural production and
reduce poverty
later the chinese leadership established
special economic zones to attract
foreign companies and grant state-owned
enterprises
more freedom china quickly became the
factory of the world
beijing then gave a massive boost to the
construction sector building roads
bridges
buildings and railways today the economy
of the world's most
populous country is still growing not
even the financial crisis
or the kovic 19 pandemic could put a
stop
to that well for more i'm joined by
fraser howie he's an
expert on china and the author of the
book
red capitalism he joins us from
singapore good to have you with us
now the full title of your book says
the fragile financial foundation of
china's
extraordinary rise interesting there is
the world fragile
what role do you think will china's
economy play
10 years from now
well look i think if you're simply
looking at the economic numbers then the
chinese economy is going to be bigger
it's certainly probably going to
continue to grow the headline growth
rates will be lower
it will clearly still still be a very
dominant player on the global economy
but how nicely creative it will be how
innovative it will be how much it will
be able to reach
or will its companies be able to reach
beyond it it shows are still far from
certain
i would also say as well there on this
days we celebrate the 100th anniversary
it's very important to remember in china
that you simply can't separate economics
from politics the party certainly does
not do that
xi jinping sees the politics
instrumentalist to the economics
and i think it's very important we
remember that because we're coming into
a much more volatile time i believe for
china
and keeping those two things together is
very important
now if you say that xi jinping sees the
party politics
politics also instrumental for the
economy
i mean the economy has done pretty well
where does a communist
lit country like china fare better than
democratic economies like germany or the
united states
well frankly it does not german per
capita or u.s per capita
gdp is multiples of what it is in china
china's
rise over the past 40 years has brought
it to basically average rates
of global per capita gdp we must
remember as well that for the
first 30 years of communist party rule
they largely ran the economy into the
ground there was a reason it was a
peasant economy
in the late 70s and that was because of
communist policies
it's been the communist party getting
out of the way and letting chinese
themselves
take control of their lives which has
driven this phenomenal growth
but ultimately china still remains
relatively a poor country
so there are problems ahead can you name
a few
sure there's a lot of problems ahead
there's a number of them that obviously
there's domestic issues of demographics
that there's an aging population
they have relatively low school
attainment rates their health metrics
are relatively poor
but i think the biggest problem they
have is i think there's
xi jinping's geopolitical overreach that
the geopolitical situation for china has
become a lot worse
since he's come to power he has
basically picked a fight with the us and
much of the rest of the developed world
and yet china is highly dependent on the
good will of the
the rest of the world for semiconductors
for oil for many other commodities
to continue its growth so i don't think
the past 40 years are at all a good idea
but a good sort of model to think about
the next coming years in china
all right teresa howie there china
expert and the author of the book great
capitalism thank you so much for sharing
your insights with us
you